hallo leute ich bin's wieder carey von
easy german und wir haben schon lange
keine zuschauer kommentare mehr
beantwortet und wir haben so viele
kommentare bekommen in den letzten
wochen wie noch nie und deshalb haben
wir jetzt mal wieder eine karre
antwortet und hier sind eure fragen als
erster sprechen über das thema tabu
topix in deutschland und das war
wirklich der wahnsinn weil es haben sich
so viele leute gemeldet auch dieses
video ich glaube wir haben mehr
kommentare in diesem video als in
irgendeinem anderen video und das hat
uns wirklich sehr gefreut weil natürlich
kann man auf der straße nicht mit
jemandem und jedem sofort über
tabuthemen sprechen aber umso mehr habt
ihr euch bemüht darüber in den
kommentaren zu diskutieren
und wir fanden das wirklich toll ich
lese mal einen kommentar vor julie julia
schreibt in der älteren generation
drogen ein tabuthema da kann man meist
nicht mal übers kiffen sprechen ebenso
homosexualität für meine großeltern ist
das immer noch was abartiges und wenn
eines ihrer enkel homosexuell wäre
würden sie es bestimmt vor ihren
bekannten verheimlichen
und dass er das stimmt juli nick ich
empfinde das auch so es gibt natürlich
viele themen die einem nicht sofort
einfallen um so wichtiger oder umso
besser ist es auch vielleicht solche
kommentare auf youtube zu nutzen um
darüber zu sprechen
und du hast noch viel mehr geschrieben
unter anderem hast du uns folgendes
erzählt der tod und das sterben sind ein
großes tabuthema
ich habe dass das habe ich gemerkt als
meine mama im sterben lag es ist ein
riesenproblem dass es nicht genug
einrichtungen wie hospizen app die den
sterbeprozess begleiten können es wird
hinter verschlossenen türen gestorben
und kaum oder gar nicht darüber
gesprochen niemand kann mit dem prozess
die mit etwas natürlichem was zum leben
gehört wie das geboren werden umgehen
das empfinde ich tatsächlich auch so
krankheiten sterben sind ein riesen
tabuthema in deutschland und es ist
wirklich sehr sehr schwierig darüber zu
sprechen und sobald jemand irgendwie ein
krankheit hat sie krebs zum beispiel mit
der alle leute sofort den tod verbinden
oder jemand tatsächlich im sterben liegt
ist es manchmal sehr schwierig und
manche leute melden sich plötzlich nicht
mehr oder leute haben angst jemanden
anzusprechen oder was falsches zu sagen
also das denke ich auch ist eines der
größten tabuthemen in deutschland wir
haben noch sehr viele andere kommentare
bekommen und ich möchte euch einfach
einladen dieses video noch einmal
anzusehen und euch auch die kommentare
durchzulesen denn ja so eine
interessante diskussion hatten wir
wirklich selten bei easyjet und wir
haben viele diskussionen also schaut mal
rein liest die kommentare auch über die
tabuthemen anderen ländern und schreibt
eure meinung dazu
unsere nächsten kommentare sind zu dem
video was wir mit dana gemacht haben es
ging um tipps für amerikaner zum deutsch
lernen
auch hier haben wir selbst die
kommentare bekommen und 2 sind etwas
typisch oder sind häufiger vorgekommen
also schreibt zum beispiel valentin
tucker bielefeld ich heiße ist an sich
nicht falsch so würde man den satz als
rheinländer oder auch als wechsel
beginnen wenn wert daraufgelegt wird
rein hochdeutsch zu sprechen dann wäre
es falsch das stimmt natürlich das haben
wir etwas unerwähnt gelassen auch in
manchen regionen in deutschland nutzt
man ist und man sagt ich statt ich und
man spricht generell dass ch wie ein sch
aus vor allem im rheinland ist das der
fall
aber das muss man das nie sagen das ist
eine lokale variation und wenn ich einen
ausländer die in deutschland von dem ich
ja sicher weiß dass er nicht im
rheinland geboren wurde weil er
vielleicht aus amerika kommt dann würde
ich das trotzdem als fehler empfinden
also man kann nicht einfach sagen das
ist dann ein lokaler dialekt aber man
sollte wissen dass es das gibt im
rheinland rede tatsächlich soll also ich
mich aber das hört man natürlich dafür
sich dann sagen ich bin vikarie das ist
dann ganz normal dass ich irgendwie so
rede und ich sage und ich glaube wenn
man dort als nicht rheinländer hinzieht
kann man sich das auch nach einer zeit
aneignen
maria camilla schreibt auch zu dem video
na ja man sieht sich aber
häufig im deutschen auch leute im
gleichen alter aber eher wenn man älter
ist also 24 jährige die sich nicht
kennen würden sich ja schon sitzen zwei
14 jährige jedoch nicht das stimmt aber
es ist auch eine generation sache und es
hat es auch mit dem sozialen umfeld zu
tun zum beispiel ich bin jetzt ich werde
jetzt 33
ich würde halt alle leute dutzend die
irgendwie bis 40 sind auf jeden fall und
es kommt wirklich auf dem rahmen an wenn
sich zwei 40-jährige begegnen in einem
informellen rahmen würde ich auch
behaupten dass sie sich duzen es sei
denn sie sind sehr sie sind selber sehr
formell und konservativ also die freunde
die habe die 40 sind oder älter als 40
die dutzend sich auch und sie duzen sich
auch sofort mit neuen leuten die sie
kennen
manchmal sogar im beruf oder im geschäft
also hängt sehr davon ab wie man selber
drauf ist also wenn man formell ist dann
und auch formalität wert legt dann sieht
man sich immer oder wenn man in einem
formellen beruf arbeitet die leute mit
denen ich meistens abhängen die machen
das aber nicht und hier noch eine frage
von ballena tour pinker hallo karo die
please make some video gebaut healthcare
festpreises etc
solche fragen bekommen wir häufig und
wir möchten tatsächlich auch filme
drehen in situationen oder in bestimmten
institutionen
wer uns dabei helfen können das seid ihr
wir sprechen natürlich manchmal auch
unsere freunde an wie zum beispiel bei
jochen dem anwalt waren wir letztens
haben über anwälte gesprochen aber auch
leute von euch laden uns ein wert wurden
zum beispiel eingeladen von tomomi einer
japanischen zuschauer in die in berlin
in einer bäckerei arbeitet und wir
würden uns freuen wenn ihr euch auch
eine art wir werden demnächst etwas
öfter machen
also wenn ihr ein arzt in deutschland
seit und in einem krankenhaus arbeitet
dann ladet und doch vielleicht mal ein
fragt das krankenhaus ab das ok für die
iss oder auch wenn ihr irgendwo anders
arbeitet wir freuen uns sehr also wenn
ihr einen interessanten beruf habt oder
eine institution in der er arbeitet und
ihr denkt das könnte nützlich sein dort
mal eine easy german episode zu drehen
ladet uns bitte ein
schreibt uns eine e mail an info at the
german doctors ein zweiter eine zweite
anmerkung diese aus cham ist unter
anderem dieser kommentar von juliane
titel
wir benutzen in der vergangenheit nicht
immer als wir benutzen es in der
vergangenheit nur bei einmaligen
ereignissen bei sich wiederholenden
ereignissen benutzen wir auch in der
vergangenheit wenn zum beispiel als ich
gestern meine oma besuchte war sie
glücklich
das ist nur ein mal aber wenn ich oma
besuchte war sie immer glücklich das ist
quasi sondern über etwas spricht was
öfter passiert das stimmt wir haben das
in unserer betrachtung ausgeklammert als
wir das im video gesagt haben allerdings
muss man wissen
in so einem satz würde man im englischen
nicht wenn übersetzen sondern so etwas
wie whenever und dem deutschen wird das
auch meistens dadurch ausgedrückt dass
man sagt wenn immer ich meine oma
besucht habe oder jedes mal wenn ich
meine oma besucht habe also man man
drückt im deutschen schon aus auch aktiv
dass das öfter passiert ist also das ist
es gibt diese ausnahme aber ich denke es
trotzdem hilfreich sich allgemein zu
merken dass als in der vergangenheit
benutzt wird und wenn in der zukunft und
wenn man wenn immer wenn er sagen möchte
dann kann man tatsächlich auch wenn
immer in der vergangenheit sagen dass
als kleine zusatz anmerkung zu unserer
episode mit dana zum abschluss habe ich
noch eine ganz persönliche bitte an euch
und zwar möchte ich euch etwas erzählen
von einem projekt das mir sehr wichtig
ist und an dem ich arbeite
wie viele von euch wissen habe ich noch
einen job neben isidor wenn ich arbeite
für einen verein den ich selber
mitbegründet habe und wir setzen uns für
den interkulturellen dialog ein und aus
dieser arbeit unter anderem ist auch
tatsächlich easy german entstanden und
was wir im moment machen ihr wisst dass
flüchtlinge ein großes thema sind in
deutschland wir wissen dass manche von
euch auch flüchtlinge kritisch sehen
aber viele von euch haben uns in der
vergangenheit
angesprochen und gesagt ich finde das
toll was wir machen dass wir uns
einsetzen für integration und ja wir
haben jetzt ein projekt wo wir wirklich
eure hilfe gebrauchen können
damals in 2015 heißt diese
flüchtlingskrise passiert ist haben
viele deutsche sich gefragt wie sie
einen beitrag leisten können um
flüchtlingen zu helfen und um ihn in
deutschland ein neues leben zu
ermöglichen und wir haben damals mit
einer gruppe von menschen ja eigentlich
wir haben viele junge flüchtlinge
kennengelernt durch unsere arbeit im
verein aber auch bei ise german und wir
haben ihre geschichten gehört und ihre
geschichten sind jetzt alle sehr
bewegend und wie soll ich sagen sind
sehr persönlich und sie verändern auch
etwas in einem
und diese geschichten sind zum beispiel
etwas was wir uns in deutschland schwer
vorstellen können wir können uns nicht
vorstellen dass jemand einen vater hat
der verhaftet wurde und von dem wir seit
drei jahren nichts mehr gehört haben
oder wir können uns nicht vorstellen wie
es ist wenn der beste freund plötzlich
stirbt durch einen anschlag im land oder
wir können uns nicht vorstellen wie es
ist wenn man ja weg geht und plötzlich
mit seiner familie getrennt ist durch
grenzen die man nicht überwinden kann
und all diese geschichten haben uns sehr
berührt und wir haben uns überlegt was
können wir machen um die situation von
flüchtlingen zu verbessern und unser
thema ist der dialog und wir haben ein
programm überlegt wo wir die jungen
flüchtlinge eine gruppe aufbauen die in
schulen gehen und in deutschland darüber
erzählen was ihnen passiert ist und was
ihre persönlichen geschichten und
perspektiven sind dieses projekt heißt
live bekommt ihr könnt dort mehr
erfahren und live beck home.de und ich
möchte euch einfach einladen
das projekt mal anzugucken und ganz
konkret haben wir im moment die chance
eine förderung zu gewinnen wir sind
nominiert für den deutschen
integrationspreis und wir haben ja die
chance wir möchten das projekt
fortsetzen im letzten jahr haben wir
über 1000 schülerinnen und schüler
besucht es hat wahnsinnig gut geklappt
und es war ja auch sehr emotional ist
ein toller dialog dadurch entstanden
und im nächsten jahr möchten wir uns in
diesem jahr möchten wir noch mehr davon
machen und wir können eben eine
unterstützung gewinnen und brauchen
dafür unterstützer denn die leute mit
den meisten unterstützern die gewinn
wiederum einen förderpreis und wir haben
nur noch zwei tage zeit heute samstag
das ganze schließt am dienstagmittag und
bis dienstagmittag müssen wir noch
ungefähr 50 bis 60 spenden sammeln und
wir dachten vielleicht habt ihr auch
lust unser projekt mit fünf euro zu
unterstützen
fünf euro reichen total aber wir müssen
eben möglichst viele leute dazu gewinnen
und wenn ihr lust habt unsere arbeit mit
geflüchteten in deutschland zu
unterstützen
dann geht bitte auch die seite die heißt
max dot com flash back home und dort
könnt ihr in drei minuten uns ganz
einfach unterstützen damit wir diese
arbeit fortsetzen können den link posten
wir hier unten
danke dass ihr zu gesehen hat bei dieser
neuen folge von kari antwortet januar
schluss noch ein hinweis auf das video
this would like to protect and how you
kurze porträts many of you know am
nächsten tag von andy project manager
thorsten storm has really important
stories
brakes and health systems the way to
integrate bisher in germany and make
berlin ihr hier
das ist what we do we were nominated for
the german in der deutsche
integrationspreis björn auer dass
integration and we have the way to the
top of the board support package
supporters dankeschön dass sie alle
zugesehen habe wieder schickt uns bitte
eure fragen schickt uns mehr fragen
wir mögen es anfang zum antworten und
wir versprechen auch dass wir in zukunft
noch regelmäßiger fragen beantworten
werden als es jetzt tun
dankeschön und bis bald
[Musik]
[Applaus]